i'm the owner of a
salvage business and i have a job over
i want you to help me break into the
most secure vault in the world
okay very good do you know who
francis drake was he stole the spanish
treasure and that's
what's in the bag untold wealth
you probably need a safe cracker i'm an
engineer i need your mind
or others to see an impossible task you
might see a solution
the war room meet the team a computer
with
acquisitions planning and extraction
made one of the world's brightest minds
he's gonna mastermind the infiltration
the vault
what it is how it works we can't work it
out no one has
and if we get caught we're going down
for a very long time are you sure you're
prepared for that
are you kids got balls
the bank of spain the most impenetrable
building on the planet
across the street is the headquarters of
the spanish army on alert for any
attempts on the bank
when spain plays its world cup games
every camera will be pointing away from
the building
which gives us 105 minutes to get the
job done
simple stage one vault keys
he's a college kid you're putting our
lives in his hands
[Applause]
big problem just stay until the job
you're good
you